so
this crew is one of a kind
everyone has a very distinct personality
everyone has been an incredible joy to
work with i mean most
most are people i've known for a long
time so that's made it
really special it's not just a film set
it's a
i mean it's just it's like a group of
great friends hanging out and we just
happen to be
making some really cool stuff we don't
have a lot of like you know
people in dedicated roles no one
dedicated to doing script no one
dedicated
to doing continuity i love the vibe all
the cast and crew seem to have like a
really good symbiosis together so i feel
like there's a lot of teamwork involved
um i feel like everybody's helping
everybody else so
it makes the whole process of shooting
kind of effortless and
easy to go through
are we rolling yeah how are you i'm
michael caradano i'm the producer for
blood from stone
tonight we're at atomic liquors we are
doing our first major fight sequence we
have our uh
our actors out here working out the the
details of the choreography
our director jeff ryan would like to do
all of this in one take so it's uh
it's uh it is it's just like a dance
they're choreographing the
the steps the moves the punches and uh
see if we can't make this exciting for
everyone to open the movie
you can see that the way he frames stuff
there's a long shot
and he conducts them in a very
theatrical way
where you have this long scene where
there's no cheating there's no cutting
there's no every two seconds like in
hollywood movies like
turn of the head next shot turn into the
head next shot i mean it's like a
broken puzzle this is more like a solid
piece
even though of course he's going to cut
it but working with him is pleasurable
because
he would allow me to to build myself
throughout the scene
that's one of the biggest problem in the
movies because in the movies because you
can't
get the momentum you get on the set they
wake you up hey
here's your scene when you cry you're
your eyes out and you're like whoa wait
i just woke up you know but in a theater
you would build up to that well
jeff does that he allows these long
scenes that was really good that was our
first solid one in my mind
i was telling people about the
production i was like it's like a six
person crew they're all doing like
10 jobs everyone's super awesome we're
doing these crazy night shoots and
everyone's just being like
such team players and like making a
really cool
story come to life so that's been super
exciting to see because i didn't know
how big the crew is going to be coming
out here
hi i'm nika i'm one of the producers
um we're just filming one of the opening
scenes for the film actually
um so we're outside of atomic blickers
and
i'm making some cocaine it's been a
complicated process putting drips of
water into sugar making
it clump today i want to show you guys
some of our dead bodies
so right here we have sweet leonard took
me a while to get his hair correctly
um what we did actually was we bought um
a long weave of hair
and then just snipped that up and mod
podged it on here
so sweet leonard you're going to have a
rough night
i feel like there's a lot of teamwork
involved um
i feel like everybody's helping
everybody else so it makes the whole
process of
shooting kind of effortless and easy to
go through
oh
it's pretty much ego free set and and
but talented and artistic people and
then of course everybody has a good
sense of humor so when you combine all
these things i mean there were so many
fun moments
we were here in nevada in pioneer saloon
in the boonies
and i'm about to kill a bunch of folks
in a good old western bar
uh i don't know what his name is sam the
bartender or something
one two three
[Music]
can you do that yeah perfect apparently
i end up
leaving in a body bag
which is all good action
nice i felt really good that was the one
that was a winner
yeah awesome we don't want to get into
the ice more that way a little bit more
that's great
michael give me a thumbs up thumbs up
yeah
michael look at the camera there she is
it's okay it's a wrap that's all we
needed
you know like some directors are really
crazy about like you get the lines
perfect and he was he was
obviously you have to know the lines but
he was he was like very
uh free about that he was just like if
you want to
you know add something or make it more
alive then
you can do that and that that really
helps a lot because it makes me kind of
feel free to live in that
space and in that moment
when you make a piece of heart you're
sending it out to the world
and you have no clue who you'll get uh
to hear back from i would like actually
to ask them what did you see there
what do you think it was about i feel a
much bigger sense of responsibility
because there's so many people involved
that are putting so much themselves into
it
nice that was the winner yes glad we did
that one for fun
obviously not for a big paycheck they're
doing it because they believe in the
project they believe
in what i'm trying to accomplish with it
and so that's really the hardest part
is making sure every day that i'm
delivering the best i
can in all those different areas so that
all the effort that's being put into
this
everyone else feels like it's worthwhile
you guys are just chit-chatting and [ __ ]
there was this general sense of like
group accomplishment that came together
it was one of those where none of us
knew if it was going to work out because
we were
trying to pull off something that would
normally be you know everybody knew
the constraints were under to do that
and so when we accomplished it you could
just see this general sense of
joy exhaustion accomplishment and just
this group camaraderie that
made it all possible it's not an easy
road it's all consuming
we'll see where this one goes i'm hoping
it's a film for everyone as opposed to
no one
hopefully they liked it but the very
least i want them to walk away feeling
like they just got a very
unique experience that they haven't seen
before
let's do it let's do it
you